you know you're seeing people that are
able to give to other people you know I
tried to do it with money we didn't have
and that would get him even more angry
now how could you be angry I was doing
something I thought was nice and yeah
but we don't have the money to do it I'm
Paul I'm Karen and we're from this area
Cleveland Ohio we kind of recognize that
financial piece is is not just the name
financial the piece there is really what
changes your life the that was a sign of
my failure and I wanted to get rid of
all evidence of my failure
I paid for house so tell me the story
what happened six years ago it was it
was like being at a hamster wheel we had
our first mortgage second mortgage on
our home we had a rental property first
mortgage second mortgage and it was just
it was stifling and suffocating and just
thinking this is what we have to look
forward to for the rest of our lives
she's friends with my sister and they
were going to the same college together
and just I was there one day and we met
you had long hair and a beard and just I
don't know I just was so mean yeah yeah
it was it was late 70-79 had a lot in
common
had a lot of fun together and she has a
Jetta Camaro that I could drive
fortunately when we got married I had a
job I was working full time making
decent money Paul was making decent
money he had no children
we had a condo that we owned because
Paul had bought it and run it at prior
to us getting married
I had the first baby and married about a
year and a half and then we bought a
house and we kept the condo as a rental
we bought other rental property and this
was all done with debt so by the time we
moved into this house 22 years ago we
had one house to live in to rental
properties
one two three four five mortgages on
these three properties plus other stacks
of that - that was just overwhelming
well the thing one of the turning points
was when the one two family we had this
is a rental
it was a two family side-by-side and the
one side was not rented and I kept
asking Paul what's going on you know
what do you what's why are we spending
it why have to do a couple things over
there
so this had gone on for quite a while so
I went in there and the ceiling was on
the floor there was a hole in the
ceiling and I cried and I thought what
happened what is this
and then I'm mad I'm like this is what
he's saying needs a little bit of work I
was livid livid to the point where it's
a good thing he wasn't with me I mean
I'm not a violent person but I don't
know what I would have done I could not
believe that the disaster I walked in on
what was he was saying it just needs a
little a little bit of work
even as all the stats stacked up I never
thought that obviously this easy debt is
the problem that's what I should have
thought some I'm not I'm not proud of
now ashamed to say but I'd come home and
see groceries you know the cupboards
full of groceries I get mad at her
because she went shopping and why we
didn't have the money for that well I
had to use a credit card to get the food
because there was no other money so I
was very content in my mind to be the
typical husband who complains about how
much his wife spends just everything
you've seen in every sitcom since 1950
you know I was pretty arrogant I thought
I knew a lot about it so I just kept
making bad decisions because I thought
that was okay I kind of kept Karen out
of the loop of any decision-making so
the only way she got to participate was
the fielding anxiety well we probably
listened to the radio show for first on
CDs so he started listen to live shows
for maybe another few months and so it's
probably six or eight months total after
we had started this that we took FPU I
think that I really heard some of the
debt free screams and knew of the
despair we were in with each other and I
just said we have to do something I said
you want to try this and she said yes
and I just was very happy we said we are
100% on board with this and he promised
me and I promised him that this was we
were going to do this no matter what our
lives were negative we were negative
everything about us was negative and the
whole it's like a community of uplift
nasai K it's just so positive that was
another benefit of it is that we didn't
see the negative of everything when we
finally got rid of the second mortgage I
knew that I think we both knew this is
doable we're gonna be able to get this
done
she changes everything has changed how
generous we can be things we want to do
Karen oh the big thing Karen was able to
go to school and her 50s she always want
to be a teacher
she's able to go get a degree in
teaching and we've completely cashflow
that you know I have friends who are
retiring from teaching and they're like
Karen you're not going to make any money
and I said it's not about the money
we're just so hopeful that because FPU
showed us all these strategies and
methods and our kids saw it for a long
time we're really confident hopeful that
they don't have to make the same
mistakes we did we are we have five
grown children youngest is 18 the oldest
is 27
they have seen us go through this whole
process we knew we were very close to
paying off the house that we called to
make the appointment to come to come to
Nashville and go to the lobby oh and you
brought a bunch of people with like you
brought the whole party here I made
party yep this is it right here our
legacy this can stick with them forever
so maybe they can you know do I want to
say they can be rich that's not really
the point point is they can have
financial peace and financial options
financial peace is not just a name I
think it just gives you a sense of I
don't know what is it it's peace yeah
it's just a masterpiece pretty much all
right Paul and Karen Cleveland Ohio
first time in 30 years of marriage
completely debt-free house and
everything in their 50s 324,000 paid off
in six years making 90 then 80 now
making 117 count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream praise the Lord Jesus
three two one
bad
that's how it happens